A otimização clássica é uma etapa crucial nos algoritmos quântico-clássicos
como o variational quantum eigensolver ou o quantum machine learning.
Porém, muitas vezes é difícil minimizar
funções complexas em espaços de parâmetros de alta dimensão.
Meu nome é Victoria Lipinska e neste vídeo vamos explorar
rotinas de otimização clássica para algoritmos quântico-clássicos.
Problemas de otimização não são fáceis.
Quando o número de parâmetros cresce, também cresce o número de
combinações possíveis de valores, e esse crescimento é exponencial.
No xadrez, por exemplo, há 64 casas
e cada jogador tem 16 peças. Após cada jogador mover uma única peça,
existem 400 posições diferentes. Após dois movimentos, 72.084 posições,
cerca de 9 milhões após três e cerca de
280 bilhões após quatro movimentos.
Se chegarmos a apenas 40 movimentos, o número de posições possíveis
é estimado em torno de dez elevado à potência de 120.
Jogar uma partida perfeita exigiria explorar todas as posições
possíveis, e esse crescimento enorme significa que percorrer
todas as posições individualmente é inviável.
Isso pode ser resolvido dividindo o problema em dois subproblemas menores.
Primeiro, precisamos determinar quais configurações do tabuleiro
têm probabilidade de aparecer nas próximas etapas do jogo.
Vamos chamar isso de nosso subespaço de interesse.
E segundo, dado esse subespaço, precisamos determinar qual jogada é a melhor.
Vamos chamar isso de nossa melhor jogada.
Nessa analogia, a busca inicial pelo subespaço de interesse
é o análogo do nosso algoritmo de otimização clássica.
Uma vez que esse subespaço de interesse é conhecido,
um algoritmo quântico geralmente é responsável por encontrar a melhor jogada,
dado esse subespaço.
Vamos começar considerando apenas um parâmetro,
theta, parametrizando uma função de custo que desejamos otimizar.
Se plotarmos a função, suponha que ela se pareça com isso,
no eixo X temos os valores do parâmetro theta
e no eixo Y está a função de custo.
Lembre-se de que a função de custo pode ser um custo financeiro real
que desejamos minimizar ou, como é frequente no variational quantum
eigensolver, pode ser uma energia que é minimizada pela natureza.
Nosso objetivo é encontrar o theta
que corresponde ao menor custo.
Começamos com um valor inicial de theta e, a cada etapa de otimização,
encontramos um novo theta que reduz ainda mais o custo.
Parece que sabemos com facilidade qual direção seguir no gráfico, se conseguirmos vê-lo.
Mas a dificuldade na otimização é que, na prática, não sabemos.
Só descobrimos o custo — um pequeno pedaço do quebra-cabeça completo —
quando avaliamos a função no theta selecionado.
Essa é a forma geral como a otimização funciona.
O otimizador amostra parâmetros theta e calcula o custo.
Como você pode imaginar, escolher aleatoriamente o parâmetro theta para reconstruir
toda a topologia da função não é muito eficiente.
Em vez disso, o que os otimizadores inteligentes fazem é calcular
o gradiente da função em cada etapa.
Dessa forma, o otimizador sabe qual direção no gráfico
deve seguir para encontrar o menor custo.
Quando o gradiente é zero, o algoritmo termina
e o mínimo é encontrado.
Esse mínimo pode não ser o mínimo global.
Pode ser um mínimo local,
ou seja, é o menor valor da função de custo na vizinhança
mas não em todo o intervalo de theta.
No caso de um parâmetro, isso certamente é possível.
Porém, quanto mais parâmetros temos,
mais complexa a função se torna.
Já no caso de dois parâmetros, temos uma superfície,
e no caso de quatro, nem conseguimos mais desenhá-la.
Assim como no exemplo do xadrez, reproduzir todas as possibilidades
rapidamente se torna intratável.
Vemos que é difícil minimizar
funções complexas em espaços de parâmetros de alta dimensão.
No entanto, para obter resultados razoáveis, queremos que as rotinas
de otimização clássica sejam rápidas e precisas.
Elas também precisam ser robustas ao ruído,
que terá um efeito significativo nos computadores quânticos de curto prazo.
Os algoritmos de otimização clássica podem ser amplamente divididos
em duas classes — busca direta e métodos baseados em gradiente.
Os métodos baseados em gradiente requerem informações sobre o gradiente
da função durante o processo de otimização.
Isso pode ser calculado analiticamente
ou aproximado em um cálculo de diferença finita.
Os métodos de busca direta não utilizam informações de gradiente
e usam outras estratégias para minimizar a função de custo.
Alguns dos algoritmos de otimização mais utilizados
no cenário da computação quântica são os seguintes otimizadores.
COBYLA significa otimização restrita por aproximação linear
e é um algoritmo de otimização sem gradiente.
SLSQP é programação sequencial de mínimos quadrados,
um algoritmo de otimização baseado em gradiente.
Ele usa um vetor de perturbação estocástica
para calcular simultaneamente um gradiente aproximado da função de custo.
Em um ambiente sem ruído, otimizadores como COBYLA
e SLSQP mostraram convergir mais rápido que SPSA.
Os otimizadores clássicos têm seus próprios parâmetros
que você pode especificar para casos particulares, por exemplo, o tamanho do passo.
Esses parâmetros geralmente podem ser encontrados na documentação
relacionada ao otimizador específico.
Encorajo você a conferir a lista de referências abaixo para uma comparação
dos otimizadores clássicos mais atualizados.
Vamos explorar mais um fenômeno relacionado
à otimização clássica de circuits quânticos parametrizados.
Como vimos antes, um gradiente nulo da função de custo pode indicar
que o otimizador acabou em um platô sem características interessantes, o chamado
"barren plateau."
Um barren plateau pode ser resultado de muitos fatores.
O gradiente da função de custo correspondente a um circuit quântico
com parâmetros inicializados aleatoriamente
decai exponencialmente para zero com o número de qubits.
Isso ocorre porque o espaço quântico explorado pelo otimizador
torna-se exponencialmente grande quando o número de qubits aumenta.
As maneiras de resolver esse problema incluem reduzir o número de parâmetros
e, portanto, a dimensão do espaço subjacente.
Outra forma de pensar na origem do problema do barren plateau
pode ser a natureza agnóstica ao problema do circuit parametrizado
diante de um espaço de parâmetros exponencialmente grande.
Projetar um circuit de forma adaptada ao problema considerado
pode ser uma boa solução.
Além do espaço de parâmetros exponencial que induz barren plateaus,
outros fenômenos físicos também podem gerá-los:
o ruído e a decoerência presentes nos experimentos de computação quântica,
a expressividade geral do circuit parametrizado,
ou a não-localidade e o grau de emaranhamento da função de custo modelada.
Ainda é uma área ativa de pesquisa abordar esses desafios.
Tendo agora revisado os componentes principais do VQE,
vamos resumir o algoritmo no próximo vídeo.